merci Elsa effectivement deuxième partie
de la Voix est Libre la question du jour
c'est où va la droite pendant que les
militants UMP sont en train de voter on
devrait peut-être dire d'ailleurs au vu
de nos discussions où vont les droites
pour passer chez René Raymond en tout
cas vous avez prononcé un mot dans la
première partie de l'émission qui va
quand même probablement occuper l'UMP
dans alors programme ok on a compris il
va falloir vous
bâtir quelque chose mais il y a aussi le
mot bien sûr primaire qui agit tout le
monde
et les socialistes pourront nous en
parler aussi d'ailleurs
Sébastien Martin on sait que Nicolas
Sarkozy allez pas bien chaud pour des
primaires ouvertes dans lequel tout le
monde pourrait voter un peu à l'image de
la à l'image de la gauche est-ce que
c'est Nicolas Sarkozy est très bien élu
ce soir comme le dit certains
observateurs il va torpiller les
primaires ouvertes
moi je veux bien qu'on fasse du débat
pour du débat et proposer les mêmes
questions mais il a dit à plusieurs
reprises il y aura des primaires
ouvertes il la redit dans le Figaro du
25 novembre il y aura des primaires
ouverte et honnêtement de quoi avoir
peur si ce soir
si ce soir
mais peut-être que sur ce sujet comme
sur d'autres il a pu évoluer considérant
aussi que le système des primaires avait
peut-être permis de à la gauche de
gagner mais peut-être pas d'avoir le
même meilleur président de la République
je sais pas c'est peut-être en
s'inspirant de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui qu'il a eu cette réflexion
mais aujourd'hui le débat est clos il y
aura des primaires en 2016 et des
primaires ouvertes voilà et maintenant
on va les organiser voir les modalités
d'organisation de ces primaires c'est un
chevalier donc contact primaire ouverte
et en même temps
Bruno Le Maire a quand même fait
remarquer qui considérait qu'il y avait
une incompatibilité entre être président
du parti et candidat aux primaires
c'est aussi pour ça que j'ai fait le
choix de Bruno Le Maire
nous pensons que le président de l'UMP
ne peut pas être candidat au primaire
ouverte
on a besoin d'équité d'équité vis-à-vis
de tous les candidats de l'équité dans
l'organisation et de les quitter dans
les moyens financiers qui seront
octroyés aux candidats et cette primaire
je crois Sébastien l'a dit tout à
l'heure
c'est un véritable atout pour pour la
droite et le centre
disons-le c'est quand même un peu ce qui
a fait élire François Hollande
cette foule cette masse le peuple de
droite qui est en mesure de se mobiliser
pour ces primaires je crois que ça
créera un véritable élan pour gagner la
présidentielle
je peux juste préciser il y a quand même
deux choses il y a au moment de la
primaire se pose la question de savoir
si on doit toujours être président en
exercice ou non de la formation en
politique qui est organise ça c'est une
question et l'autre question au nom de
quoi est-ce que le leader de la première
enfin du plus grand parti d'opposition
aujourd'hui en France n'aurait pas le
droit d'être candidat à la primaire ou
alors ça veut dire que le leader de
cette formation
ou alors ça veut dire que le leader de
cette formation politique est quelqu'un
qui n'a pas de poids qui n'a pas idée et
qui n'a pas d'envie de faire changer son
pays donc dans ce cas là il fallait
surtout pas le mettre là il faut surtout
pas imaginer le leader d'un parti
politique comme ça donc je pense qu'on
est d'accord sur le fond finalement
c'est au moment de l'élection qu'on
s'entende bien le président de l'UMP
peut évidemment être candidat aux
primaire évidemment en revanche devra se
remettre il devra se mettre en retrait
de la présidence de l'UMP c'est ce qui a
fait pour garantir justement cette
équipe
de nos primaires on a quand même scindé
justement pour une question de
neutralité et de pas forcément peut-être
éviter le conflit d'intérêt à un moment
donné parce que quand vous êtes à la
tête d'un parti d'une institution en fin
d'un organisme qui met en place
justement toutes ces toutes ces
installation pour les primaires ça me
semble logique qui est une séparation à
un moment donné il a dit Stéphane
chevalier c'est probablement les
primaires qui ont fait élire François
Hollande
je pense que les primaires ont été une
très bonne chose même peu importe du
résultat qui qui en est finalement qui
en découle à la suite parce que c'est
aussi la voix finalement des militants
et au-delà des sympathisants et de tous
ceux qui ont voulu justement en interne
et même au-delà de du Parti socialiste
rapprocher les citoyens je trouve que
c'est très démocratique on va pas se
leurrer dans nos parties la voix des
militants tout à l'heure vous étiez en
train de prôner justement la possibilité
à vos militants de s'exprimer encore
plus et prendre peut-être des décisions
aussi c'est ça aussi je pense qu'on
prétend tous autour de la table à plus
de démocratie au sein même de nos de nos
propres parties c'est un peu le travail
qu'on doit tous faire avant même de
prétendre à avoir des responsabilités à
la tête de notre pays ou à la tête de
nos institutions aujourd'hui la
démocratie c'est ça même à l'intérieur
de nos parties c'est une question
est-ce qu'un parti qui est au pouvoir
peut se permettre d'en faire une aussi
moi je suis favorable des primaires en
2017 au sein même de mon parti et
ouverte c'est-à-dire au-delà du Parti
socialiste quitte à rassembler toutes
les sensibilités
ou pas on le sait pas aujourd'hui
Pourquoi se dire qu'on est en train de
décrédibiliser un candidat il est
président de la République aujourd'hui
il n'est pas candidat et on est qu'à
deux ans de son mandat les cellules le
temps autant encore une fois
Guillaume Mayer primaire ouverte ça veut
dire l'UDI dans la course avec un
candidat avec quel est votre position
vous Jean Christophe Lagarde devrait
être candidat à cette primaire faudra
s'entendre avant François Bayrou devra y
être aussi de puisque on a vu qu'il
semble se rapprocher de la droite quel
est votre position là dessus écoutez ma
position faudra poser directement la
question Jean-Christophe Lagarde parce
que je pense que pour le coup c'est ça
le concerne directement alors je vous
coupe et je cite sa parole qu'il a qu'il
a écrit dans un tweet bon 146 certes
s'est passé juste après les sifflets sur
Alain Juppé à Bordeaux il a écrit Jupé
sifflet à Bordeaux quand il évoque le
centre cela laisse songeur quant au
primaire ils veulent nos voix mais pas
de nous
donc c'est peut-être pas si simple que
ça ah mais il y a rien de simple on
politique vous le voyez au sein de l'UMP
non je pense qu'il faut
il faut attendre effectivement que le MP
choisie son président qui se qui se
restructure que l'UDI se restructure
aussi nous avons deux formations qui ne
sont pas si éloignées sur pas mal de
thématiques après ce qu'il y aura des
primaires ouvertes
je pense pas être habilité à répondre
alors de façon générale pour la
démocratie ce que vous pensez que c'est
une bonne chose
c'est une bonne chose parce que je pense
que le problème qu'on a c'est qu'il faut
réconcilier je dirais les sympathisants
de nous de nos formations politiques
autour d'un projet les problématiques du
parti des étiquettes de parties c'est
une chose par contre les sympathisants
autour de thématiques de société
d'économie de réforme là sont livrés
enjeux aujourd'hui pour pour construire
un programme après la démocratie au sein
même la partie si un candidat est
légitime et ben je pense que les
sympathisants et les adhér ents le
mettre en avant
vous avez évoqué il y a quelques
instants la possibilité du MoDem et de
François Bayrou à cette primaire
clairement je dis non François Bayrou a
permis l'élection de François Hollande
il y a deux ans il doit en assumer
toutes les conséquences
véritablement si on veut rassembler le
peuple de droite et du centre il faut
que les règles soient claires du centre
disons de la droite
et de l'UDI les règles selon moi doivent
s'établir entre ces deux formations
politiques je crains que si le modem
venait à être associé à cette primaire
une partie de notre électorat pourrait
nous abandonner je n'oublie pas qu'à
Dijon le modem fait alliance avec le
Parti socialiste c'est toujours plus de
dépenses toujours plus de subventions
toujours plus d'argent gaspiller
de ce que les concitoyens en ont
vraiment je pense ras le bol de ce
clivage politique de se dire parce qu'il
a le côté
France
à la tête de notre pays depuis 30 ans il
faut arrêter on a tous nos torts et faut
le dire arrêtons aussi ce clivage
politique en disant oui c'est de la
faute à la droite la faute de la gauche
les alliances parce que Monsieur Bayrou
a dit je me prononce en faveur de
François Hollande aujourd'hui vous
voulez pas être dans sa stratégie moi je
trouve ça un peu parce que les Français
justement aujourd'hui en ont marre je
vais pas la prétention de parler au nom
des Français mais pour avoir justement
tendu l'oreille auprès de comme vous
vous le faites dans votre exercice ils
en ont marre de ce clivage là il faut
surpasser c'est pour ça qu'à un moment
donné dans le discours de de Nicolas
Sarkozy quand il dit c'est vrai il était
peut-être en responsabilité et un moment
donné il disait je rejette le système
des parties c'est pas pour rien qui se
pose cette question aujourd'hui alors
j'en profite je m'engouffre parce qu'il
nous reste 3 minutes mais il y a quand
même un thème qu'on a pas abordé qui est
important c'est le produit Front
national aujourd'hui dans toutes les
dernières élections quand on parle de la
droite ou va à la droite sur sa droite
et là le Front national donc est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui de votre point de vue
alors on se connaît la position de votre
tendance de votre aile on va dire
Sébastien Martin c'est que c'est Nicolas
Sarkozy qui est le plus à même
d'empêcher de Front national
d'arriver en tête au premier tour de la
présidentielle mais ce qui empêchera le
Front national de prospérer c'est pas
Nicolas Sarkozy tout seul ce qui empêche
le Front national de prospérer c'est la
capacité que l'on a à apporter des
réponses à toute une partie de la
population qui se désespèrent et qui est
aujourd'hui elle est à l'extrême droite
mais qui a quelques années était lecteur
du Parti communiste certains étaient
électeurs du Parti socialiste ont été
lecteurs du RP ils viennent de partout
ces gens ils viennent de partout parce
qu'ils ont le sentiment d'être laissés
sur le côté par les formations
politiques traditionnelles qui ne leur
parlent plus elle est là la question et
donc le vrai sujet c'est est-ce qu'on
est capable ou non de répondre à
l'inquiétude de ces personnes et donc de
proposer quelque chose de nouveau parce
que les recettes jusqu'à présent n'ont
pas fonctionné c'est enfin et pas de
savoir si on doit être juste à côté
derrière à droite au milieu au centre je
suis d'accord elle est de la qualité du
discours comporte et des propositions du
projet qu'on aura en 2017 pour répondre
à une situation de crise qui est
l'avantable et catastrophique voilà le
sujet
par rapport à l'éventualité je partage
complètement la vie de Sébastien Martin
moi je crois pas providentiel je crois à
des valeurs à des principes ce que nous
disent nos militants nos sympathisants
plus globalement l'électorat de droite
dans nos réunions publiques c'est quand
vous êtes élu faites le travail pour
lequel vous avez été élu rassemblez-vous
unissez-vous et appliquez le programme
une bonne fois pour toute pour lequel
vous avez été élu alors il nous reste
peu de temps dans cette émission je
profite de vous avoir tous les deux pour
vous demander un pronostic Sébastien
Martin ça va être quoi le résultat non
je vais pas me lancer au petit jeu des
pronostics d'autant que très honnêtement
il y a beaucoup de chiffres qui
circulent et moi je me souviens d'une
chose c'est des chiffres qui circulaient
avant l'élection à la présidence de
l'UMP côté Fillon qu'est-ce qui vous
ferait plaisir vous vous souhaitez quoi
Nicolas Sarkozy a une large largement
c'est que dès ce soir on est un
président de l'UMP qui soit élu le plus
largement possible bien évidemment bien
évidemment allez moi ce qui me fera
plaisir ce soir c'est que l'ensemble des
dirigeants de l'UMP soit ent rassemblés
qui sont en capacité de se mettre au
travail dès demain d'avoir un discours
cohérent clair précis et de rassembler
encore une fois notre électorat et de se
tourner véritablement vers les Français
merci à tous les quatre on a fait
conclure les membres de l'UMP compte
tenu de compte tenu de l'actualité
merci bon week-end à tous ne manquez pas
ce documentaire à 15h20 sur Pierre Joxe
il vaut vraiment la peine je vous le
conseille au revoir merci